Hans here's what I'd like to know do the
European creditors does the Eurogroup if
you will or the euro summit feel more
confident about negotiating with some
kind of coalition because that's almost
inevitably what we're going to find in
Greece a few days from now because once
syriza rebels mutinies which is about to
happen in order to get this as this bill
passes parliament tsipras mandate within
his own party has to have evaporated you
know Eric this might be a slightly
paradoxical answer but they don't really
care they say that's an issue that's a
challenge for the Greek government of
that is not necessarily what they need
to be occupying themselves with what
they need to be occupying themselves
with is their end of the conditionality
and that is if this if this preliminary
agreement this really agreement to move
forward passes their passes the Greek
parliament and then passes their
Parliament's then we can move forward
the idea that mr. tsipras was forced to
sign some pretty difficult terms
everyone here there's not a lot of
sympathy for mr. tsipras because in some
ways that was a grave of his own digging
Mike let's let's talk for a moment about
the fact that you know what Hans just
alluded to there is this deal in
principle and I suppose those who feared
a grexit ought to be relieved this
morning but there's a lot that has yet
to happen well of course they've got to
get it through their Parliament in
Athens and then six European
Parliament's have to agree that then
they start a bailout deal negotiation
it's important to realize this is not a
bailout deal these are only
preconditions to even start talks so a
lot has to go forward before we get to
the point where we can say grexit is not
an option anymore it's still out there
what about the capital controls we were
told over the weekend that the capital
controls are going to remain in place
but there might be a lifting on the cap
on bank withdrawals yeah well these are
good for the time being the ECB isn't
doing anything if he did nothing they
kept they kept the aid in place but
didn't raise it today and that's likely
going to be their stance until we see
what happens on Wednesday if the Greeks
get through this this through Parliament
they will probably agree to give them a
little bit more money but it's still
going to be very hard to open the banks
until there's some certainty if you were
a Greek would you put money back into
the bed I was you thinking about you
saying it out
deposits are probably zero and when you
say they kept the aid in place well
that's not really anything because the
aid has all been used up so yes they
still have an 89 billion dollar line of
credit but they've drawn all of that
line and given out almost all of the
cash I'm hearing they may have the banks
may have enough money just to continue
dispersing cash in the next two or three
days Hans let me ask you you spoke with
the Finnish finance minister early this
morning I watched that and he said no
bridge financing there is he repeated
three or four times to be clear no
bridge financing but they'll talk about
that this afternoon and tonight yeah so
right now finance ministers are meeting
on this idea of bridge financing what i
heard mr. Stubb say was no bridge
financing without conditionality but
that means that to have initial just say
it's 10 or 15 billion whatever price tag
you say to get them through august that
is part of a separate deal that will
also require as i say prior actions from
the greek government one other
interesting aspect of that mr. Stubb
interview and of course the Finnish
finance minister he said that a bank
bailout would not be coming from the ESM
the banks have a cash a huge cash
problem right now they have a shortage
of a massive magnitude how they figure
out some sort of way to get frantic to
mainline cash from either the ECB or
from some liquidity line into the Greek
banks is a huge question it's an open
one and so far no one's provide any sort
of concrete or comprehensive actions
guys might back to you here in New York
City let's draw a distinction if we can
between the politics of these
negotiations and this deal in principle
and the economics what are the economics
of what mr. tsipras had to agree to this
weekend well greased had started to grow
by the end of last year now they're back
into recession and there's going to be a
lot more pain in the short run if they
pass these reforms because they're going
to be raising taxes and they're going to
be cutting pension payments now down the
road what people are saying is Germany
has forced german-style labor market and
business reforms on to the Greek economy
and over the longer term that should be
good for the economy to help it grow
they want this 50 billion dollar bailout
fund that put the assets of Greeks into
a fund that so they can
sell them off that was supposed to my
god in the 2010 agree the water utility
for one the electric utility for another
they mentioned specifically by name they
agreed to do that in 2010 and never did
it what chippers did get out of this is
an agreement that they can take the
proceeds put them back into the bank's
put them back into some
productivity-enhancing investments in
Greece so over the longer run it should
help Greece grow but they'll have some
short-term pain I got to jump in and ask
Hans you know I heard a lot about this
50 billion dollar fund privatization
fund over the weekend a lot of
politicians a lot of finance ministers
skeptical that the Greeks have assets
that are worth 50 billion dollars if you
don't include include like the Acropolis
and the Acropolis and and Mykonos I mean
do they really have utilities worth 50
billion dollars it's aspirational so if
you listen to the way a variety of both
Prime Minister's Chancellor's and
finance ministers have been talking
about that 50 billion it's pretty clear
that's a target that's the number they
want to get to now valuing those assets
is going to be a massive fight and
that's one of the reasons why initially
they want to put it in Luxembourg now
it's going to be administered it's going
to be house in Athens and it'll be
supervised the supervision will come
from the EU but look that number I don't
want to call it funny money but that's
the goal and that's where they want to
get half of that money supposedly with a
bank rescues going to come through so
what if you don't get to 50 you still
need to find 25 billion for the bank's
got it all right so we'll agree not to
call it funny money putting a value on
those assets though should be pretty
easy right whatever people are willing
to pay for them is how much there were
take awhile to figure that out